all right starting January 7th they will
be starring on Broadway and it's only a
play and this new memory is called I
must say perfect title my life is a
humble comedy legend Martin sure
[Applause]
Martin
I'm ventriloquist thank you for
having me on the show and thank you for
the awesome contact hi
[Laughter]
all right you with your comedy remarks
but thank you you've been on our show
many many many town of our favorite
guests one of the few a-listers who can
handle the panel I must say but tonight
tonight is different because tonight you
wrote a memoir I did so this is about
you it's hard for you to talk about you
get 72 God's spell it all scenes before
me how did you get the courage to work
up to talk about yourself I don't know
it's a whole different ya know I think
that this is a fascinating I love you
know I love Larry David's quote what a
wonderful book if only it was about
someone else well I I read it from cover
to cover I devoured it like a fine tofu
I took told you about that and yes we
had dinner a few weeks we did and I
picked up the tab but go on
I'm sorry about those things I broke in
the restaurant anyway the thing I was
telling you at dinner was that I found
so many things in this book where we had
areas in common I did not know about yes
like neither one of us had a father who
sat at the table during dinner mine cuz
he was working yours was in the next
room no he was in the same room that is
so weird well no I'll tell you because
my father was born in cross with Glen
County Armagh and our Northern Ireland
and he kept the old ways he'd have his
big meal at lunch so when he'd come home
from the office
I know when he'd come home for the
office he'd have a gin and ginger no ice
one of many and sit there and just kind
of attack us as we were eating that is
weird no matter what countries from he
could be from Neptune and that would be
odd that don't mistreat sits in the same
room but does not eat dinner with you be
reading the newspaper and just looking
Marty don't shovel the food in like an
animal there don't go where you'd stand
up and say Michael keep eating I'll make
sure the dogs don't get that job you
know all right second thing we have in
common is that we both spent a lot of
time in our room as children imagining
we had a TV show I mean you imagined
what was it called the Marty the Marty
show of variety hour I was on the I was
on NBC every other Tuesday at 8:00 they
wanted me every week so yeah and I
didn't have time for my imaginary film
career
and that's really why you actually have
a TV career isn't it because well I but
it was interesting because I was in
Canada it didn't seem realistic to
pursue anything so I wanted to I went
into medicine no really I was gonna be a
doctor because I was a fan of Quincy and
but it wasn't enough I mean I know you
got the American TV show yeah we got we
got all the American shows and we got
Canadian networks and the British
television and I think that's why so
many satirist scum from Canada and okay
so the third thing I think we have in
common is that people think we're Jewish
and we're not no we were both raised
Catholic yes wcv school yeah yeah no
it's true my father had a my best friend
I had a lot of Jewish friends all my
friends right sure we know Jews yeah
we're not disowning that you know saying
people think with my friend Mitchell why
do you think they think we're Jewish
well because I think we're thrifty the
dinner I don't know I I have no why do
people think your Jewish nose my nose I
think it's the nose I think they think
my nose is Jewish I do I think they
think I do I have funny and have a big
nose I know this isn't like a pug here I
mean it's no but you don't have no I
don't know is like me I I think maybe
it's I think it's because I grew up with
a lot of Jewish people and maybe I you
know got rhythms or styles or things
like that you know which is the original
looking of this book right I'm Sebastian
you have freedom hum those are the
titles yeah surprised they don't think
you're gay with
yeah but the other thing I loved in the
book was the description you were
referring to earlier of like when you
started in Toronto you call it kind of
like a Paris in the 20s feeling I was
almost jealous reading about that and
all the people who you started with who
were now Fame I mean Paul Shay for the
people you were in Godspell with dr.
Garber all the SC Gilda Gilda Radner
fielder Rodney your first real life
Andrea Martin did people know that that
the first real love and mr. Martin Short
was Gilda retro and but John Candy Danny
Aykroyd all his eyes were Hilmer Bill
Murray yeah and they were all hanging
around not working right we'd party yeah
it was funny Paul was always playing
piano party that's really that's pretty
good thank you fabulous thank you so
much all right look like half man half
baby carrot right and then and then you
talk about of course your real love your
beautiful wife and and you know you talk
about loss I mean you lost your brother
you lost your parents you lost your and
you and you somehow always are able to
maintain your happiness and and you I
mean it your book almost made me cry
there at the end because people are
trying to set you up on JDate for once
and for all but you know you still talk
to your wife you know it's hard for you
I think one of the worst thing of losing
so my wife and I were together for 30
over 36 years and I think the worst
thing when you lose someone is the
assumption that now oh you're not to
talk about her no one mentions her it's
like she didn't exist and I love one of
the reasons I wanted to write this book
because I wanted to make her come back
to life and you really did and it's it
Wow that's okay
so
and you there's a part of it where you
say you know that you I mean you're not
a religious person look but you you had
an experience when your brother died
that was almost spiritual because before
you knew he died you felt awful like a
half hour before you got the I did I
what do you explain I don't I can't
explain it's never happened since and
but it's not one of those things where
you have a dream and and you dream that
the person who's passed visits you and
you feel better the next day because a
scientist could explain it one way in a
spiritualist the other but certainly
when my brother David died that morning
I was at camp and I felt weird and I
felt like something strange and I
couldn't explain it and I'm not not ever
depressed and I was kind of depressed so
I don't know what that was I don't know
what it means well I mean even as people
who don't are not religious believe I
think most of us that we don't have all
the answers I certainly don't I mean
your uric someone who was I think we
have three people on the panel who were
born Catholic and have given it up and
one person who stuck with it stick with
it more of a challenge more of a
challenge okay